Hi everybody, welcome to this
week's episode of YouTube
Developers Live.
I'm Jeff Posnik, coming to
you from New York City.
And this week we're going to
be talking about how to
discover great content, both
YouTube videos and YouTube
channels, using the latest
YouTube Data API version 3.0.
So let's actually dive
right into things.
This is kind of a companion
piece to a blog post which
details some of this
information in
kind of written form.
So feel free to refer to
that, we'll have a
little annotation going.
Or watch the video for
some real examples.
The first thing that you might
want to do when helping your
users of your application
discover great content that
they might want to watch is
make use of the type of
ranking and discovery that
we already use on the
YouTube.com home page.
So we actually do have an API
call in version 3.0 of the
Data API that will give you
back more or less the same
information that users see
when they go to the
YouTube.com page while
they're logged in.
And this is the recommendations
for videos
that might be relevant to them
based on all sorts of
different signals.
So you as the application
developer don't have to worry
about that.
You can just make an API
call and get back some
great shows to watch.
So I'm going to actually
switch to the demo.
And I'm going to do all these
demos using what we call our
APIs Explorer.
This is a great tool for playing
around with the API
calls we're going to talk about
today, but also just any
of our Data APIs or
Analytics APIs.
If you're just getting started,
I'd really recommend
checking out this tool.
Again, we'll have an annotation
pointing to it so
you can go there and try to make
some sample API calls.
So this is, in particular, a
YouTube Activities List call
that we're going to make.
And we're going to pass in
a couple of parameters.
We're going to put the part of
snippets, and that's just a
common part that we
use through a
lot of our API methods.
It means give me some common
data about the videos that are
being returned, such as a title,
a link to the video ID,
things like that.
And in particular, we're going
to do something a little bit
different that you might
have seen before.
We're going to pass in true
for this home parameter.
And what this means is instead
of making a traditional
YouTube Activities List call
where you get the list of
recent activities for a specific
channel, or your own
activities, passing in home
equals true means please give
me the list of things that would
normally show up on the
YouTube.com home page.
So it's a little bit
special there.
And I'm going to click Execute
down here and I'm going to get
back a 401 Unauthorized because
there is something in
particular about the home
equals true parameter.
It only works right
now if you are
authorized using OAuth 2.0.
So it has to be personalized to
you and your own relevant
activity, but the API needs
to know who you are first.
So it's actually really easy
using the API Explorer to
generate an OAuth 2.0 token.
I can just to do
it using this.
But if you're a developer and
you're looking to integrate
this into your application,
you're going to have to take
some steps to have your users go
through the OAuth 2.0 flow.
It's made a lot easier by our
client libraries, we have lots
of material available, including
some good guides on
our developers on the
google.com/youtube page that
talk about how you can go
through the OAuth 2.0 flow.
One thing to note if you are,
for instance, wanting to take
a user through the OAuth 2.0
flow, but you don't have a
keyboard in your scenario.
Maybe you're writing an
application that's on some
sort of embedded device
or television,
something like that.
There is this particular OAuth
2.0 flow that you can use, and
it's called OAuth
2.0 for Devices.
And it's really well suited
to this use case.
Basically, it allows a person
to log in and authorize on
some computer that
they have nearby.
And then your application
running on a different machine
is able to pick up the
authorization.
So it's pretty nifty.
Again, consult our
documentation for more details.
But in this case, I'm sitting
in front of the computer and
I'm making use of the handy,
built-in OAuth 2.0 support in
the API Explorer.
So I'm just going to click On
right here, and I'm going to
click Authorized.
And you just saw something
flash.
I've previously authorized
access to the API Explorer for
the account I'm logged in.
So you didn't see the
full OAuth 2.0
authorization screen.
But what this means is if I go
here and click Execute again,
we're getting back a response
in this case.
And this is the same sort of
things I would see if I were
visiting YouTube.com.
Some videos that might be good
recommendations based on all
sorts of different signals.
So you could then display this
in a user interface and have
folks select the videos that
they want to watch.
So that's a great experience.
There are some other ways though
that you might want to
help users discover new videos,
and not necessarily
tailored to their recommended
YouTube activities.
And this kind of equivalent
to Most Popular
Charts, let's say.
Which is a concept that might be
familiar to some folks who
have done previous development
using our older
version 2.0 of the API.
Let's say you wanted to retrieve
a list of popular
videos that meet certain
parameters.
So there are a few different
approaches for how you could
do that in version
3.0 of the API.
One way that you might want
to do that is starting by
retrieving a list of different
categories.
So YouTube will maintain
different lists of popular
videos broken down by
various categories.
And you could display a list
of those categories to your
users and say, hey,
select a category.
And after you select a category,
your application
displays relevant popular
videos there.
So assuming you want to take
that route, the first call
you're going to want
to make is at
YouTube.videocategories.list.
Again, we're going to pass in
that snippet parameter.
And in this case, we are
going to pass in
a region code parameter.
I am going to put in the US, but
any two character country
code should work.
And I don't need to
be authorized.
It's not making use of any
personalized data or anything
like this, I can just go through
it without having an
OAuth 2.0 token.
And I'm going to get back
a bunch of these video
categories.
These might be familiar to
anybody who's been on the
YouTube.com website and has
browsed through categories,
the direct link there between
audio and video vehicles,
category, music, film and
animation, and so on.
Let's look in particular
at this
Pets and Animals category.
Everybody likes going to YouTube
and finding some great
pets videos.
So the relevant piece of
information here is the title,
Pets and Animals,
and the ID, 15.
It's a little confusing
because there is
this channel ID.
This is more or less just a
placeholder value, it's not
relevant to your API calls.
What you really care about is
this ID value over here of 15.
And after, let's say you
present a list of these
categories to your user, the
user's chosen a specific
category, you do a follow up API
call to actually get the
most popular videos
in that category.
And you do that using our
YouTube.videos.list operation.
So you're going to want
to put in again
the part equals snippet.
And the charts, right now we
only support retrieving the
most popular videos, so that's
the only value that
you could put in.
You do need to make sure that
you have chart equals most
popular set because otherwise
it's a completely
different API call.
And we're going to scroll
down a bit.
There are a lot of different
parameters that are
potentially supported, but
again, I'm going to put in the
region code here because I want
results that are specific
to the United States
in this call.
And I'm going to take that video
category ID I got in the
previous step.
Just go back there for a second,
it was 15, for Pets
and Animals.
And I'm going to put that
in right over here.
So I'm going to click Execute,
and here are some great videos
related to pets or animals.
You can see, pretty relevant.
But if I were to change the
region code from US to JP for
Japan, for instance, you'll
get a completely
different set of videos.
I will fully trust that that
is Japanese characters and
these are videos that are very
relevant in Japan in the Pets
and Animals category.
So that's a good way that you
can get some really customized
charts depending upon the
category you're interested in
or the region code that
you're interested in.
So that's cool.
One of the things that we talked
about before, but is
also related to video discovery,
is making use of
Search And in particular,
Search that's powered by
Freebase or Google Knowledge
Graph topic IDs.
So I'm going to put another
annotation in this video that
points to a previous show that
we've done that goes into
great detail about what Freebase
topic IDs are and
gives you explanations on how
you could look up the relevant
topic IDs for a specific
concept.
But in the interest of brevity
in this show, I'm just going
to give you one concrete example
of how you could do a
YouTube Search List operation.
And we're going to pass in a
topic ID that I looked up
previously, and this is the
specific topic ID that
corresponds to American
football.
So this is actually a nice way
of narrowing down exactly what
you're interested in finding
instead of putting in a
generic search term of football,
which might match
things that are European
football, otherwise known as
soccer, or might match things
that are not directly related
to American football.
Putting this topic ID in here
means all the results that I
get are definitely related to
American football, and that's
a great way of discovering
content when you know exactly
what you're looking for.
So those are the two fields
that I've filled in.
I click Execute, and
the results are
all related to that.
So there are some additional
parameters that you could put
into your search call, things
like Published Before,
Published After, different
orderings.
So take a look at our
documentation on that.
It's a great way of finding
content they you might not
otherwise have found
specifically related to a
given topic.
So we've talked about how you
can find videos using version
3.0 of the API, but you can also
find channels that your
users might be interested in
either subscribing to or just
viewing the recent activity
related to those channels, see
some videos that have
been uploaded into
them, things like that.
And we do have API calls that
are related to channel
discovery as well.
So much like we started the
process of finding video
categories by doing our Video
Categories list in the process
of finding channels,
you first do a
YouTube.guidecategories.list.
It's not called channel
categories, it's called guide
categories.
So be sure you're
clear on that.
But this is the right
call to make.
You do part equals snippet, and
again you pass in a region
code, two character
country code.
You click Execute, and you'll
get back these results.
So things like Best of YouTube,
featured channels,
paid channels, music channels,
comedy, so on.
Go over here, let's get
some gaming channels.
Everybody loves gaming
content on YouTube.
So this is the value that we
want over here, the ID value.
Again, the channel ID that is
also returned is not going to
be really relevant, it's just
kind of a placeholder value.
So the two relevant things are
the title, which is Gaming,
and the ID, which we're going
to copy right over here.
And you take the values from
that previous call and then
you can do a
YouTube.channels.list call.
So again, part equals snippet.
The category ID is that previous
one that we looked up
for gaming.
And we're going to click Execute
down here, and we get
our standard JSON response.
But this time we're getting a
bunch of information about
channels, not individual
videos.
So you'll see in this case the
five channels that we think
are the most relevant to that
particular category.
And at that point, you could
display information about the
channels, do pretty much
whatever you'd like.
So hopefully that gives folks a
good idea on how they could
use the latest version of the
Data API to do some common
operations related to both video
and channel discovery.
Thanks for watching the show.
As always, I want to plug the
fact that Google Developer
Relations, which is the team
I work on, is hiring.
So you could visit
developers.google.com/jobs and
find out more information
there.
And thanks very much for
watching the show.
We had a bunch of different
links in the show, links to
blog posts, things like that.
Check out some of the
annotations in the video
description.
We'll include all those links
there so you can read more
about the topics we covered.
Thanks everybody, have
a great week.